Santiago Muy buenas tardes el juez Juan
Carlos checkle validó la posición de la
fiscalía que señalaba que para tener
éxito el delito de rebelión no era
necesario que esté consumado Qué
aconteció es que la fiscalía venía
señalando que Pedro Castillo hizo una
violación flagrante de la
constitucionalidad y el orden
democrático y al disolver el parlamento
y convocar a las fuerzas armadas para
que respalden sus medidas extremas esto
constituía el delito grave de lo que se
conoce se está hablando en estos
momentos de Conspiración y también de
rebelión Esto fue rebatido por la
defensa de Pedro Castillo que señalaba
que no puede existir el delito de
rebelión ni tampoco de Conspiración
porque para que eso se constituya se
requiere el alzamiento en armas Pedro
Castillo no se alzó de armas y tampoco
vio al parlamento Pues bien el juez Juan
Carlos checkle luego de oír las
ponencias terminó por apoyar la posición
de la fiscalía es así que Pedro Castillo
va a tener que
tener una detención preliminar por siete
días en la prisión de barbadío donde es
compañero de celda del expresidente
Alberto fujimori apenas comienza
entonces este proceso judicial contra la
expresidente Castillo Francisco también
hace pocos minutos o hace unas cuantas
horas la presidenta Dina boluarte en
unas declaraciones dijo que por ahora
descarta la posibilidad de convocar a
elecciones anticipadas qué más dijo la
mandataria
bueno Dina boluarte lo que quiere la
presidenta nueva de Perú es que haya un
consenso y ahorita más se enfoca en que
haya la continuidad democrática del
periodo
2021-2026 ella está enfatizando
esfuerzos para atender puentes con los
diversos grupos del país y también
generar confianza y armar un nuevo
gabinete de gobierno vamos a escuchar lo
que habló Dina boluarte
Yo sé que hay algunas voces que indican
adelanto de elecciones Y eso
democráticamente es respetable creo que
la Asunción de la presidencia en esta
oportunidad es un poco reorientar lo que
hay que hacer con el país más adelante
en coordinación con todas las
organizaciones
estaremos viendo alternativas de mejor
reorientar los destinos del país
Francisco para terminar este esta
actualización de lo más reciente que ha
ocurrido allá en Perú muchas personas se
siguen preguntando qué sigue entonces
para el expresidente Castillo en materia
jurídica que hay por delante para Pedro
Castillo
Bueno lo que sucede es que ahorita la
defensa de Pedro Castillo se está
reagrupando hay que tener en cuenta que
no solamente renunciaron sus ministros
de estado sino también sus abogados el
anterior Primer Ministro Aníbal Torres
ahora lo está defendiendo y están
tratando de ver cómo interponen recursos
de Amparo y algunas acciones en la
justicia peruana entre ellos en el
tribunal constitucional y en el frente
externo también van a recurrir a la
Corte Interamericana de Derechos Humanos
porque ellos consideran que se han
vulnerado los derechos del expresidente
Pedro Castillo entonces va a haber una
actividad legal tanto de parte de la
fiscalía como de parte de la defensa de
Pedro castillo y sobre todo en estos
momentos la defensa de Pedro Castillo va
a tratar de ver cómo liberarlo Esa es la
situación a la cual vamos a estar
atentos en